MAGGIE: Hi, I'm Maggie,
and I'm looking forward
to helping you get
started on your journey
to becoming a Google Certified
Mobile Web Specialist.
You start your
journey on our website
by checking the certification
requirements page.
Have a look at the other content
on the site such as the FAQs,
then download the study guide.
Use the study guide
to make sure you're
ready to take the
certification exam.
The study guide describes
what the certification exam
covers and contains links
to study materials you
can use to help you prepare.
When you're ready, sign
up to take the exam.
You'll continue on our
exam vendor's site, where
you start with a
compatibility check
to make sure that you have
the best experience possible.
The compatibility check tests
that your system meets the exam
requirements for things
like your monitor resolution
and connection speed.
Next, you provide
payment information
using your credit card.
To validate your
identity for the exam
and to ensure that your exam
results and certification are
only attributed
to you, you upload
your government-issued
picture ID.
For most countries, you
need a current passport.
To make it easy, have a
clear picture of your ID
ready to upload
on your computer.
Then you take a
photo of yourself.
After paying for your exam, you
schedule your exam for the time
and place you plan
to take the exam.
You'll have four
hours to complete
the challenges, plus 10 minutes
to take the exit interview,
with a short break in between.
So give yourself at
least 4 to 4 and 1/2
hours to complete
the exam in a place
with a consistent
internet connection.
Be sure to pick
your time carefully.
If you miss your scheduled
time by more than an hour,
it will count as one
of your three attempts.
After you schedule, you'll
be at your candidate portal.
This is a place
where you can always
go back to see the status
of your certification.
At your scheduled exam
time, you start the exam
from your candidate portal.
You'll receive an email reminder
10 minutes before your exam
time with a link to the portal.
After checking your system
and connectivity one
more time, you log into
a Linux exam environment
where a desktop is waiting
for you with coding
tools such as Atom and Chrome.
Read through the instructions,
and then start working
through the coding challenges.
Use the editor
provided to write code,
then check the
results in Chrome.
You may use the internet while
taking the exam to look up
resources, but be aware that
you cannot copy and paste
into the environment
from your own browser.
Although you can use the
browser provided in the exam
environment, be
careful not to copy
and paste anything that could
be construed as cheating.
Be sure to always save
your work before moving
to the next challenge.
If you need to start
over, each task
has a backup folder
with the original files
that you can copy to
the working folder.
A timer shows you how much
time you have remaining
to help you pace yourself.
If after four hours you
haven't submitted your exam,
any work that you saved is
automatically submitted.
Even if you stepped
away from your computer,
or there was a
network interruption,
as long as you saved your
files, you don't have to worry.
When you're ready to submit
your exam, open the Submit page
and click Submit.
After you submit your exam,
you can take a short break
before you have to start
the exit interview.
You must start the exit
interview immediately
after the break, or the
interview will expire and count
as one of your exam attempts.
During the exit
interview, you'll
answer questions about the exam
in a 10-minute timed interview
using your webcam
and microphone.
The purpose of
the exit interview
is to ensure that your
exam results are only
attributed to you.
Before you attempt
the interview,
be sure to remove any personal
belongings from your workspace
to protect your privacy.
Next, answer the questions
to the best of your ability,
and then click Submit.
The upload process may take
some time, so please be patient.
If the exit interview fails
to upload after a few minutes,
be sure to contact
support immediately.
After submitting
your exit interview,
check your candidate portal.
The candidate portal
tells you how you did,
and if you did
not pass, lets you
know when you're eligible
to attempt the exam again.
Thanks for listening, and
good luck on your journey
to becoming a Google Certified
Mobile Web Specialist.